[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
the deadly uvaldi school shooting we
trained our kids to sit under the table
and that's what i thought of you know
at the time
but we set them up to be like ducks hear
from a teacher who survived the attack
and that's why johnny depp lost in uk
and that's why he won the trial here the
differences in the johnny depp's united
states and united kingdom trials plus
we're going to make the media pay for
what they did to me kyle renthouse filed
suit for alleged media defamation and
later things get heated in broward
county i don't intend to have any
contempt hearings but i believe
your refusal to participate with the
clear violation of florida law and
the rules of professional responsibility
the latest in jury selection proceedings
for the parkland school shooter law and
crime daily covering court cases from
coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to long crime daily i'm
your host brian buckman for the very
first time we're hearing from a robb
elementary school teacher and survivor
of last month's deadly shooting in
uvalde texas
19 students and two teachers were shot
and killed on may 24th when an 18 year
old gunman opened fire in the school 17
others were injured the gunman used an
ar-15 style rifle to shoot and injure
his grandmother before making his way to
the school he entered through an
unlocked side door and remained inside
for more than an hour as multiple
students inside the building called
9-1-1 he was later shot and killed by
border patrol agents
fourth grade teacher arnufa reyes says
he remembered his emergency training and
told students to crawl under their desks
and pretend to be asleep when the gunman
entered his classroom all 11 students
inside were shot and killed the 17-year
teaching veteran was shot twice and
struck in the arm lung and back speaking
exclusively to good morning america
reyes says it took one hour and 17
minutes from the time the gunman entered
the school for officers to enter the
school at that time multiple 911 calls
were made from inside the school and
several students inside called out to
police for that reyes says he can never
forgive emergency responders
did you feel abandoned
in that moment by police by the people
who are supposed to protect you
absolutely
after everything
i get more angry because
you have a bulletproof vest i had
nothing
i had nothing
you're supposed to protect and serve
there is no
excuse
for their
and i will never forgive them
i would never forgive them
in the wake of this shooting families of
four students injured in the shooting
have filed a suit against the gunman's
estate all students involved in the
lawsuit are either nine or ten years old
in a statement the student's attorneys
said the discovery process will focus on
the school system law enforcement social
media as well as gun and manufacturing
ammunition companies that means the
attorney's team will focus on law
enforcement's response to the shooting
how the gunman entered the school and
how he obtained the weapons and
ammunition the team of attorneys will
also investigate whether there were any
red flags of violence or threats that
were not reported to emergency officials
joining us today is co-host terry austin
and civil rights attorney joe richardson
joe if officers outside the school
ignored cries for help and multiple 911
calls do they not have a legal duty to
act and could they face criminal charges
well it'll be interesting to see what
happens on the criminal side but i would
say
that it's not as easy as it sounds
certainly morally wrong
you certainly could accuse them of
miscommunication at best or neolithic
mis
incompetence at least but
when it comes down to it there's
actually no duty to protect someone
that's not in your custody so the police
may not actually have a legal duty
because they're not in custody as crazy
as that might sound and
going over to the civil side we'll see
what happens there as well for the same
reason we don't know that there's a
legal duty that makes it
legally actionable on the civil side on
the criminal side i think it's a tough
road to hoe to uh to bring cases against
this fleet at least the same for the
same reason yeah now terry this is more
of a
broader conversation i guess is focusing
on police response part of the
discussion of gun violence in america or
is it a separate one and should we be
focusing on preventing a mass shooting
like this from happening again
brian we should be focusing from all
perspectives we should have preventive
measures like making sure we look at
mental health issues we should have
proactive measures like making sure we
limit gun access we can do that by
raising age limits i've said this before
increasing the waiting periods thorough
background checks and more importantly
banning assault weapons bump stocks and
high capacity magazines but we can also
look at post event measures like making
sure the children know what to do making
sure the police know what to do but that
is a last resort we have to look at this
holistically absolutely well following
the uvalde mass shooting and several
others across the country new york
raises the age requirement to purchase a
semi-automatic weapon in the state
on monday governor kathy hokel signed
the bill into law now prohibiting any
new yorker under the age of 21 from
purchasing a semi-automatic weapon on
top of that anyone who purchases a
semi-automatic rifle will be required to
get a license something previously
required only for handgun owners this
makes new york the first state to enact
a major gun control initiative following
the string of deadly shootings in all
hogel signed 10 public safety bills
among them one that would require micro
stamping on new firearms in an effort to
help solve gun related crimes another
would revise new york's so-called red
flag law allowing courts to temporarily
take guns away from people who could be
a risk to themselves or others
still ahead on law and crime daily less
than a year after his acquittal kavren
house filed suit against top social
media giants
but first comparing johnny depp's
lawsuit why the pirates of the caribbean
actor lost his uk suit but came out on
top in the united states
[Music]
welcome back an update now on our story
we first brought you here online crime
daily johnny depp files in opposition at
the aclu pushing back on a requested 86
000 reimbursement payout in court
documents filed back in april the
american civil liberties union better
known as the aclu requested more than 80
000 in reimbursement for the
organization's involvement in the
defamation case the lawsuit claims the
organization complied with a subpoena
reviewing nearly 8 000 documents in
court documents filed last week depp's
team claims the aclu is not entitled to
attorney fees the filing says
reimbursement should be limited to less
than two thousand dollars only for costs
associated with providing aclu documents
the aclu played a significant role in
the defamation suit as herd pledged part
of her divorce settlement from depth to
the organization members of the
organization also helped her draft the
washington post op-ed that would become
the basis for depp's defamation claims
in the days following the monumental
verdict in depth's defamation case
against ex-wife amber heard we're
hearing from top legal analysts some who
say critics should stop comparing the
recent united states verdict with depp's
previous trial in the uk
back in 2020 according to united kingdom
ruled against depp who sued the sun a
british tabloid after an article
referred to him as a wife beater two
years later an american court ruled in
favor of depp who claimed he was defamed
by heard in a washington post op-ed but
experts explained there were many
differences in the two trials for
example a single judge ruled against
depp in the united kingdom whereas a
jury of seven ruled in favor of him in
the united states but experts say the
most important difference is that amber
heard was not a party in the united
kingdom trial
if you are not a party to the case in
the uk trial you are not obligated to
disclose certain information to the
court
johnny depp's legal team requested the
judge for what they called a third party
disclosure which is asking amber heard
as a non-party to disclose certain
information that they need for the trial
the judge in uk denied that request by
johnny depp's legal team but at the end
of the day the uk judge does not have
all of the evidence that was presented
in the u.s trial because here amber
heard is a party to the case
which means that amber heard is legally
obligated to disclose or produce
information
as a party to the case that was not the
case in the uk trial so as you can
imagine the evidence on both trials are
different
that's why johnny depp lost in uk and
that's why he won the trial here
all right terry what do you make of
johnny depp's counter suit against the
aclu and does it
matter or help the fact that he won his
case against amber heard
i don't think that really makes the
difference but i think they filed that
countersuit to just legally protect
johnny depp i mean those claims that the
aclu are trying to make are exorbitant
they are excessive and it's not
supported by new york law new york law
provides that reimbursement should be
for reasonable expenses not for
attorney's fees maybe the aclu wanted to
protect themselves they wanted the
lawyers to look over the documents and
there were some 7 500 documents that
were reviewed they produced 2 000 of
those documents they had three witnesses
and all in all they can be reimbursed
but i think at the end of the day
they're going to come to some sort of
settlement
at a reasonable amount not at the amount
that the aclu is requesting yeah now joe
do you think the difference is in these
two cases the uk and the us comes down
to two different judicial systems uh and
causing a different outcome in the
trials or were they just two different
cases altogether
they were two different cases there were
two different legal systems different
standards also uh to the point that was
made earlier uh amber heard's villainous
nature did not exactly come through
because she was not a party in the other
case but at the end of the day this was
about having a judge versus having a
jury you just have a different
presentation when you go to the judge
there are several things that uh
the attorneys for johnny depp could do
in front of the jury that would have an
effect the cross-examinations as
brilliant as they were by camille
vasquez would not have moved to judge
they wouldn't have done been done in
front of a judge you have a completely
different strategy when you're trying a
case in front of a jury versus a judge
and i think that's the biggest
difference all right we'll see what he
does with the aclu case as well thank
you both coming up on law and crime
daily in a renewed push after the johnny
depp trial acquitted kyle rinhaus sets
his sights on defamation lawsuits of his
own
plus contention in the courtroom as jury
selection in the florida death penalty
trial for an accused shooter continues
[Music]
welcome back fresh off the heels of the
johnny depp amber her definition trial
kyle rainhouse says he feels it's now
time to push ahead with his own
defamation lawsuit rent house was
acquitted last year over murder after he
fatally shot two men and injured another
in kenosha wisconsin in 2020. the
shooting happened during riots and civil
unrest following the shooting of black
man jacob blake by a white police
officer reinhouse who was 17 at the time
says he traveled across the state line
from illinois to help protect a friend's
private property and help as a medic in
case it was needed protests turned
violent and destructive that's when
rittenhouse killed two and injured a
third man rain house now says several
media outlets and social media
personalities defamed him calling him a
murderer or white supremacist making
everyday life difficult
we're going to make the media pay for
what they did to me they made it hard
for me to live a normal life i can't go
out into public
i can't go to the store it's hard for me
to go anywhere without security shoot
doing basic things like taking my dog to
the dog park is difficult so
they made it really difficult to be
normal kyle was charged with a crime
news organizations are allowed to report
on that but you know calling somebody a
murderer in certain circumstances can be
actionable other things that
media
personalities people on social media
said were clearly defamatory
terry do you think johnny depp's recent
win against amber heard motivated this
lawsuit and do you think the fact that
depp won could help rin house do the
same
you know i'm not sure what motivated the
written house lawsuit maybe he felt
empowered but frankly i don't see his
claim prevailing i think the two cases
are completely different the depth suit
was two different cases where you had
defamatory statements made against two
individuals the written house case is
totally different he has killed two
people injured a third it was a murder
trial and essentially the press is
allowed to
absolutely report on that now yes you're
innocent until you're proven guilty but
the fact that he's got people looking at
him differently and people are talking
on social media if the press
acted responsibly and talked about the
case i don't think there's going to be a
defamation claim against i mean
obviously you have to say that it's
false and that it caused injury so i'm
not sure he's going to be able to prove
all that yeah and joe that kind of leads
me to my question for you how strong
does random house's case look to you and
would rent house be considered a public
figure like johnny depp was
i think there's an argument that because
of what was happening with him at that
time he would be a limited purpose
public figure that's not good news for
him because that means there's a malice
standard so in other words there has to
be knowing falsity reckless disregard
for truth um and it is a higher standard
and so it is difficult to show that he
has actually been defamed and even the
attorney himself says in certain
circumstances you can't call him a
murderer therein lies the rub there's an
argument that you can call him a
murderer because he did murder he did
kill that does not mean he was convicted
legally he's not a convicted murderer he
was not convicted of murder but he did
kill those two people he's not like
somebody else like o.j simpson who
claimed it didn't happen people wanted
to believe it but they never had it
proven no he actually pulled the trigger
even though he got off and so therefore
i think he's going to have a real big uh
real difficult time uh proven defamation
here i would agree there especially when
you consider what self-defense actually
means well thanks for that breakdown
when we come back jury selection in a
florida trial has dragged along but is
once again moving forward after several
motions from the defense team in the
death penalty case of the parkland
school shooter
[Music]
welcome back to long crime daily jury
selection in the death penalty trial her
florida school shooter may be moving
forward but at a snail's pace and on
monday the 23 year olds of public
defenders tried to withdraw from the
case and have the judge removed
the shooter took responsibility for the
february 2018 marjory stoneman douglas
high school shooting last october
pleading guilty to 17 counts of murder
and 17 counts of attempted murder
despite the guilty plea prosecutors
still intend to seek the death penalty
the jury selection process has been
plagued with setback after setback the
latest being a shooting at an elementary
school in texas the gunsman's defense
filed a motion to delay his trial
indefinitely saying the texas shooting
reawakened emotions arguing it makes it
impossible for their client to have a
fair trial while the judge did not rule
on that motion she did rule on two
others defense attorneys asked the judge
to disqualify herself from the case but
she denied the motion and the judge
ordered jury selection to continue even
though a second member of the defense
team who was brought in as a death
penalty expert and specialist is out
sick with covet 19. it became the scene
of a tense standoff monday pinning the
defense against the judge who had grown
openly tired of the delays
i don't intend to have any contempt
hearings but i believe
your refusal to participate would be a
clear violation of florida law and
the rules of professional responsibility
are there separate rules of professional
responsibility for a capital case
because this cites the rules of
professional responsibility and that is
when the council was ordered by the
court to go forward i i haven't heard
the court order me to go forward are you
ordering
i am
saying that the trial is going forward
for you in the the jury selection is
going forward for you to then say what
that you're going to intentionally
create ineffective assistance of counsel
is in clear violation of the reuben case
and your rules of professional
responsibility and if judge at this time
the defense would move to withdraw from
the case of state of florida versus
nicholas cruz right now if i do not
comply with the court's order and do not
protect mr cruz's constitutional rights
to due process i now have to consider
whether or not my liberty is going to be
in jeopardy or mr cruz's liberty is
going to be in jeopardy i'm also going
to have to consider whether or not
my law license can be impacted which
would impact my ability to raise my
children feed my children and educate my
children so if you're ordering me to do
that
and i fail to do that i'm at risk of
being held in contempt because i'm in a
battle right now between my liberty and
my client's liberty all right
respectfully your emotion of withdrawal
is denied
for two months prosecutors and attorneys
have been trying to pick 12 jurors in
eight alternates for the upcoming months
long trial which will decide whether the
parkland school shooter is sentenced to
death or life in prison
joe how do you think the judge will rule
on the delay based on the uvalde school
shooting
i could see perhaps there being some
delay related to the sickness of the
second attorney who's a specialist but
not because they believe that the texas
shooting has evoked emotions
frankly if you could be that reflective
every day of your life right now and
who's to say sometimes within the next
four months when this is supposed to be
going on there's not going to be another
such instance you have a right to a
speedy trial and most of the time
the judge lends toward things getting to
their resolution so they're less likely
to grant a motion to continue anyway let
alone for an arbitrary reason about
what's happening in texas because they
feel like people will be emotional about
it you can never judge when that's going
to end and therefore the judges would
have to make a choice and would not end
up continuing i seriously doubt it i
agree as well terry is there some
strategy or reason for delays like this
or is this just such a big case making
it so difficult to pick a jury listen it
may be a strategy but i think the
defense is grandstanding i really like
this judge i think she's making the
right decisions look everybody wants the
defense to be perfect you want to have
that attorney in there defending this
client making sure you have a death
penalty attorney
consequently you want to you know make
time to have him come back from being
sick from covet but at the same time you
need to have this trial go forward it's
been going on for months jury selection
has to be concluded and the judge has to
make the decision how she's going to run
her courtroom so i think there's a
little bit of grandstanding here and i
do think it's a difficult case but the
judge is making the right decisions all
right we'll see when the first juror is
selected thank you both and thank you
for joining us here on law and crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss justice in america
[Music]
you